not drinking for like two days let's do
it too because I've been trying to cut
down
and then after 24 hours or so the DT's
set in so I'm all shaky and sweating I'm
like this sucks
how much do you drink uh so I used to
drink like 18 pack plus a day like I'd
get an 18 pack and like four tallies and
chug that in just a day no problem no if
I can kill a six-pack in a day I'm doing
pretty like froggy I've been trying to
keep it to like two or three
just so I can keep meter because
eventually I'd like to do two or three
six packs no no beers just beers out of
the six pack yeah because I've been for
the last year I've been trying to cut it
down because for the longest time I was
I drank whiskey like the half gallons
every two days
just chugging it and then eventually I
started getting the shakes and I started
dting and I was like I need to start
cutting down on this so like how many
years do you do that
ah that started like two years ago and
then uh yeah I cut all hard alcohol out
of my there I was like that it's I can't
drink that and be able to survive
so I gotta just switch to beer and it
started with
way too much beer way too much beer and
then I've been slowly trying to even it
out because like eventually I'd like to
be able to you know go two or three days
without drinking a beer be able to drink
my water in my juice and stuff and then
if I want to have a beer I can have it
instead of the beer telling me that I
need to have it
I I had a really bad co-connection when
I was younger and I learned then that
like if you let your addiction take over
you it's literally going to run your
life and I don't need something as
simple as alcohol trying to run my life
I quit smoking
that was easier and they say that's just
as addictive as heroin man and if I can
quit that I know I can quit this I just
need to
keep metering it out like I am that way
the DTs get less and less but eventually
they just won't be there that's what I
Common Sense would tell you that is the
way to get off these some of these drugs
is to wean yourself off because like
with Coke I did not do that I made the
dumbest decision in my life I just cut
myself off cold turkey after like a year
doing it
the deities were so bad I thought I was
having a heart attack how did you how
did you just go cold turkey in so I quit
calling my dealer and so I had a joke
with my buddy so I'd buy 600 worth of
blow he'd buy 600 of the blow but we
give it to each other that way we didn't
have the addiction we're just giving
each other a present and that happened
for about a year and then like I watched
my bank account just this is basically
to zero and I couldn't do it anymore and
he came over one day and I was like I
didn't buy you a present this week he
was like I didn't buy you one either
dude I think we have a problem I was
like well I took two weeks off at work
he was like I did too I was like cool I
got a spare bedroom we're gonna spend
the last two weeks in here and we're
just we're just gonna kick it
that first week I thought about breaking
every window just so I could Escape but
I was on the third floor so wouldn't
have worked very well you told me
earlier that you're dead locked you into
her yeah I had him come over and turn my
paddle lock around so he could lock me
in my house so I couldn't go and he'd
show up twice a day make sure there was
food and water make sure we were good to
go like if we were sweating in the
middle of the floor we'd come and grab
our laundry for us and go do it like my
dad was my best friend he was a great
man you see he locked you in your in
your room at my apartment your apartment
he turned the entire
uh paddle or twist lock around so he
could lock it from the outside and we
couldn't unlock it
right brilliant because he had the key
we didn't what what do you drink
so it basic redneck store I grew up in a
little cow town called Snohomish so it
you know five or six years old hey Dad
can I have a drink I'm thirsty take a
sip yeah up in Washington and you'd take
a sip of beer when you're like five or
six and by the time you're 12 he's like
yeah we're out by the bonfire you can
have a beer and by the time I was 16
full blown just I had a full beard and
mustache by then so I could walk into
7-Eleven and go pick up a 12 pack if I
wanted to
like they didn't card me back then I'm
pushing 40 man this is this is back
before they actually cared and like I'd
go in pick up my 12 pack 18 pack
whatever me and my buddies go over to my
place and we just drink
and then it just spiraled and snowballed
in there that's why I made the decision
consciously that like I had I gotta
start cutting down because I'm pushing
40. like that's how people die but what
is drinking done to your life
honestly the drinking didn't do much
sadly and like I always made sure my
bills were paid like me and my wife have
almost twenty thousand dollars saved up
that's why we're traveling like I've
always made sure my bills were paid but
like the feeling is what kills me like
when you go out that one night and you
drink those three too many beers and
then you wake up and your head's all
foggy and your stomach's messed up and
you want to eat but you can't I hate
that
like I love food I'm a fat kid and not
being able to eat food because my
stomach's all queasy because I decided
to have eight beers instead of three
that's on me that's my that's my dumbass
addiction brain saying oh no no you'll
be fine it's all right it's just one
more beer it's just one more beer but
that one more turns into four more which
can turn into ten more and then you wake
up in the middle of your freaking
kitchen with vomit all over the floor
and you're like this is not how I want
to live my life
like at all so we we killed our lease
where we were living we put everything
in storage paid a year of it and we were
like hey we gotta go it's not going to
get better for me here all my buddies
are hardcore drinkers even some of my
associates are just hardcore Drinkers
and if I stay here in Port Angeles
because I moved to Port Angeles after
Snohomish sorry I met my wife but uh
I was like if I stay here I'll die like
I will literally pull Leaving Las Vegas
and I will just end up drinking whiskey
until I can no longer hold my bodily
functions anymore and I'll just die and
I I knew I had to get out of there so I
was like dude let's let's just travel
for a little is there a self-destructive
streak no that's the weird part like I'm
the one that talks people out of doing
self-destructive stuff I don't even ride
motorcycles that shit's scary
I mean I've gone really fast in a car
before but I was on a race track you
know that was a controlled environment
but like I I if when I have cars I don't
speed like I don't try to go cliff
diving like the scariest thing I do is
Surf and that's just because there's big
ass sharks out there
like I I'm not big into the whole
self-destructive thing like my my
family's always been like if you can
pick yourself up by your bootstraps do
it if not ask for the help and I've only
had to ask for help twice two times
the first time was after we lost our son
at 32 weeks
not one hurt
but I had to ask my aunt I was like I
gotta stay at your house for a couple
weeks she was like why I was like
because I'm gonna go buy like a gallon
of whiskey
and I'm gonna drink the [__] out of it
and if I'm at your house I can't drink
that much you'll give me a beer or two
and I'm cool with that
then the second time was after uh after
my dad died
I actually had to ask my brother's
sponsor if I could stay with him for a
week because it's the same thing I was
like dude I'm gonna go buy as much vodka
as I can
I'm gonna see how much of it I can drink
before I die
and uh yeah and I've only had to do it
twice but I knew I had to do it because
if I didn't I I would have probably
killed myself the worst two days of my
life
honestly what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear now is for my kids I got
a son and a daughter
and like I just
I don't want them to have to grow up
like I did like they I was super poor
when I was a kid
super duper baby there were nights when
I didn't get there
and I had to like sneak stuff from lunch
at school to bring home just so me and
my little brother could have something
so you're living homeless now you're not
making much money so my wife has Social
Security she collects native benefits
and I'm paid by the government to be her
caretaker we actually pull in almost
three grand a month that's why we're
able to travel yeah
and like yeah it's just I needed a
change in staying there wouldn't have
done anything like I said I just would
have drank and drank and drank and I
would have ended up actually homeless my
wife probably would have divorced me for
being a useless [__]
like
because I mean I've been Landscaping
since I was 16 years old and working in
kitchens the same amount of time is
there something you're trying to escape
oh no the drinking oh God no drink I
just like the way it makes me feel
honestly as long as you don't do too
much it's great like two or three beers
you're in that bubbly like I'm a happy
place kind of thing and I can normally
stop after two or three beers but if I'm
around one of my buddies or another
person who's like oh man come on just
one more round you know one more round
like all right one more round we'll have
one more round I'll turn into five more
rounds and then I wake up the next day
and I'm like why in the hell did I go
hang out with him I knew it was gonna
happen
like
just ridiculous but I knew it was going
to happen so that's why I was like we
got we gotta go and I have family in
Oregon that we visited on the way and
then our buddy Chris has family here in
California that we visited and now we're
going down to Arizona to see her family
and then eventually we're going to go
over to New York because that's where my
cousin owns his own restaurant up in
Albany and he was like dude you show up
I just I just want you to cook for me
for like a week just like a week I was
like dude I can do that and he's doing
it because you know I can't drink before
I go into the kitchen because I I've
worked in so many kitchens you don't
drink before you go into a kitchen let's
say you lose a thumb
so that's his way of being like I can
make sure to keep you sober at least
half the day
and then after that it's up to you but I
know I can keep you there for eight
hours and you can't do anything but
drink some apple juice and be happy is
there any chance this plan won't work no
how weird you have all our tickets
booked and everything no I mean just to
stop drinking well see that's the thing
is I don't want to stop I just want to
be able to cut down enough where it's
not controlling anymore like like I said
I want to be able to go you know a week
without drinking and then have somebody
be like hey man let's go out for drinks
and have two or three drinks no but I've
heard a lot of addicts say that they
have an on switch but they don't have an
off switch that that is true for a lot
of them but I have quit drinking before
I went an entire year and a half without
drinking just because I was like I
wonder if I can do it
at first it was six months then after I
got to six months I was like let's see
if I can get a date
and then I got to eight and I was like
dude I bet I can make it to a year and
so on and so forth until a year and a
half and then we lost my son and just
just all tumbled away
what do you think of Skid Row
it's terrifying holy crap
like we're over by the freaking Motel
the first night and they're literally
pouring piss on us from the windows so
that was cool then we're back over here
not last night but the night before and
some random crazy tweaked out black
chicken you cannot be here this is
awesome and I was like fine whatever
where where just across 7th Street like
fine
go over there and then our neighbor next
to us is pretty cool because I'm
allergic to opiates which is the best
slash worst it's [__]
allergy ever if I break my arm they give
me Tylenol three
but I can't ever do heroin or blues or
any of that which is freaking awesome
and I don't even drink caffeine so meth
is way out of the question and uh she
was actually really cool because she was
talking to her buddy and I heard her and
I was like Hey guys like if you want to
smoke some of that dope you want to do
it like outside of the tent so it's not
coming in towards my tent because I'm
allergic to that it'll send me an
anaphylaxis and I don't feel like dying
on skid row and she was like oh yeah no
problem dude we'll go walk around Skid
Row you're allergic to what everyone is
smoking pretty much yeah that's what I'm
just hanging out in my tent waiting for
my train
all right so I've interviewed all three
of you guys so hopefully you'll have
enough money to get out of here oh we do
we do now 263 dollars and between the
three of us that's 300 so we'll have
snack money and everything as well
snack money
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing I'd like to
love man and and I don't mean just my
wife or your friend just people in
general like you don't know what they've
been through you don't know what they're
going through it's one of the best
answers I've ever heard and like just to
have love for humans in general it
doesn't matter what race color creed I
don't care your religion like I just
gave a dude my last bag of chips because
he was like bro I haven't eaten in two
days and I was like here has a bag of
chips nobody deserves it I asked this
question of everybody I think that you I
think your answer is my favorite well
it's true man we should love each other
if everybody had just a little bit more
love the world would be a lot better of
a place
just
a lot couldn't say anything better than
that Ted thank you very much not a
problem a man thanks